what up reject nation greg
john
names established hey we're going to
watch this next episode of brooklyn
nine-nine i hear it's a funny i hear
it's a hahaha here
guys full-length watch longs are you
synced up with a timecode for a benign
over at our patreon page special thanks
to all have become super rejects by
checking out everything we got to offer
over there also leave a like
leave it and leave a like a good like if
you can and you know subscribe and click
notification bell you know if i were our
next reaction for brooklyn 99 is up hey
uh leave a comment and um the boys at
prepper want you to put down in the
comment boxes how how great of a job
um half of them have been doing and
which half you're going to specify the
praise to
nicely put
all right ladies i don't got a whole lot
of time here so what do you say we make
like boyle's mom and you debrief me it
didn't happen nice you know she tells me
everything yeah not everything chucky
she took off my undies they peralta
gross put in the major crops pile what
we've already given them all of our
felonies that's because i got a bet
going with the captain of the a4 winner
gets to choose a tattoo for the loser
guess what i'm getting them calvin
peeing on the tasmanian devil no it's
supposed to be a bad tattoo man you're
really stupid in the morning aren't you
[Laughter]
look i'm gonna make it real simple for
you we only saw mr meaner's wieners say
it you'll only solve misdemeanors
winners congratulations you just called
yourselves wieners dismissed
today
[Music]
look at that cast
ah
love all of them equally
comedy
good morning
for whom
for yum
for that shirt
i'm here to discuss the department's new
smuggling task force it asks for us
oh i thought you'd be handing me another
vapid pr assignment i am we need to
choose a phrase to replace the phrase
task force
[Laughter]
since your little stunt with the subway
poster i think you could use some
supervision
bob will be keeping an eye on you it's
gonna be fun ray but i'm his boss oh
ouch how demeaning
what a [ __ ]
we can't work real cases this is a b e
oh it's so much more than that herb came
in through the back window
set up the living room to look like a
kid's tea party
didn't steal anything the perp wasn't
there to take anything
except lives serial killer i think this
is the work of the oolong slayer seems
like a stretch if this is the oolong
slayer why isn't there a body i don't
know maybe he got spooked before the vic
got home or it could be jake you want a
case so bad you're making one up
[Music]
the vulture's orders were only
misdemeanors wieners why do you follow
people's directions when you could
literally pick them up and throw them
out the window
i hope he does that it's a good life
philosophy was that the sound of a juicy
file i heard yeah it was you just lost
your overtime privileges for the month
everybody listen up anyone caught
working on a case that i didn't assign
loses their overtime capooch
uh
kapooch
please not make this fun a month from
today it's my birthday i need you to
throw me a party all right make it epic
surprise me are you asking us to plan
you a birthday party yeah i'll kill her
because we're women women love planet
park because you're miracle workers this
is an amazing use of time we have
complete control over that dummy's
birthday party we can ruin it yeah
fun
i'll just mess up the captain's orders
on purpose
oh
look i don't know when i'll be home i'll
text you okay
oh
all this paperwork is gonna straight up
kill me i eat a cacao nib every time i
close a case a what a cacao nib yeah
happy little chocolatey delights from
deep in the peruvian rainforest yeah try
one do i look like a man who snacks you
look like eight circles with suspenders
okay fine
just one mm-hmm
yeah plus organic and fair trade
terry loves responsible agricultural
practices
give us some cocoa nibs i have an
extremely dope possibly even disgusting
case and i need to discuss it with him
if once finds out he's working on case
she will punish him she's on the warpath
right now jake loud and clear don't want
to cause a problem
[Music]
oh no
not the pigeon looks like we've both got
a pretty bad case of jerk boss yes yours
is an idiot and mine is a fork tongue
lizard witch
the oolong slayer he's back
what's your plan i'm gonna work the case
in secret
wrong we're going to work the case in
secret
[Music]
i hang out in the men's room all the
time
the acoustics are amazing
[Laughter]
great use of sound and reverb but he did
leave his calling card a tea bag in his
victim's mouth yeah how cool
diabolical re-examine all of the task
force's files two check all b and e's
against the slayer's mo and three think
of something super cool to say when we
arrest him my leading contender you're
going to jail for ooh long time ah
let's not overlook the fact that he
turned his crime scenes into tea parties
for dollies which suggests
pre-adolescent trauma leading to a
pattern of criminality that probably
began as a juvenile i'd like to propose
a toast
oh that globe
to catching a serial killer to rihanna
because i love rihanna
vigilantes and then make a true crime
podcast out of it time is it
that's right oh no he gained weight oh
new case oh no
you read 20 words that's a name they're
off the cacao you may want to slow down
on those things things
these are the precious jewels of the
rainforest boy i don't mean to overstep
here but
oh fat oh
you can't comment on my body this is a
workplace
now i'm feeling objectified by your male
gaze
you are trying to shame me and that will
not flop you go girl trace the label on
the slayer's oolong turns out he got it
at chang's medicinal tea shop good work
peralta breakthrough selfie
don't post it gina
we created the version while gina copies
his customer files uh hey punk that's my
ginkgo it's my ginkgo now old man i'm
still young enough to beat that ginkgo
out of your hands oh yeah
whoa
oh no
what an intense diversion oh no
this is so much fun hit me in the face
oh that was a terrible suggestion
[Music]
yeah all right
western medicine rules
let's see what you got for the big b day
bash i was thinking uh dj pass orders
fundraiser for french dorks all right
tough guy what do you got planned i
don't know meet at a bar and
[Laughter]
immaculate pause yeah right i mean you
only get one shot at your brother's
widow
oh my god i'm gonna get that tattooed
partner portner portner his name braxton
o'reilly oh
he's a maniac
arrested in 84 for torturing an animal
oh this is our guy
no man just a squirrel
nypd nobody moved where's braxton
o'reilly where's that psycho monster
who's dead
our condolences
oh god uh i freaking knew it you're a
liar and you you can't do anything
except disobey orders and screw up i'm
disappointed too no one cares
you didn't even get the right guy it was
an error do not interrupt me your juicy
insubordinate ass is suspended same goes
for you peralta except for the uh juicy
ass part because your ass is stupid now
get the hell out of my office you guys
suck they're gonna fuse together
screw this
it's ten days now shouldn't have gone
back in
[Laughter]
amy's been doing her best to cheer me up
meanwhile holt won't even talk to me how
is he by the way honestly terrible i've
only heard from him once this week and
that was to tell me he'd finally come up
with a new non-threatening term for task
forces do groups
can i have another port you're still
drinking that stuff yeah hulk got me
hooked on it i even got a bottle for my
house it's really classing up the booze
and take out menu's shelf
the aha
i think i just figured something out i
gotta go aren't you forgetting something
uh
oh pay your bill
damn who raised you
but i believe that hard work pays off
shut up excuse me no no shut up and look
you're completely right your hard work
just paid off
the vulture's in a band fantastic jack
oh my god just when i thought he
couldn't be any more the worst he
outbursts himself
i have an idea oh god go play his own
birthday none of the victims had any
alcohol in their apartments not even a
dusty bottle because they were all sober
they all attended 12-step programs they
all have the same leader a creep with a
record of torturing animals i'm talking
dogs
jesus
but i kind of ordered rye ma'am i'm not
a waiter okay trying to blow my friend's
mind over here could someone get this
lunatic some rat
we were just suspended for screwing up
this case i shouldn't even be talking to
you once can probably hear us right now
she has super sonar hearing
[Laughter]
just give the case to major crimes i
never thought i'd live to see holt side
with the vulture and lunch
mark the day gina may 18th at 4 p.m oh
honey we're well into october
[Laughter]
charles i thought you should know oh my
god
i'm off the news really of course i'm
terry jeffords
and when i put my mind to something
i do it
my resting heart rate is six six
sometimes we fall down
but it's how we get back up that map
like we need to look off
no
looking for me oh
nice try cop but you and i are gonna
have a little tea party am i invited
yeah oh nice
good one okay slayer
prepare to go to jail for a long time
i'll say
sir we just caught a serial killer i've
wanted this since i was four years old
that's troubling
that's troubling
i'm glad your dream came true brother
now if you'll excuse me
the drivel calls hey turd monkeys it's
time to celebrate me
wow you are an evil genius next time i
want to hurt someone i'm coming straight
to you
all right this next song is called mom's
in the shower oh my god
i spent a decade looking for this
monster and you found him all on your
own i imagine that'll look pretty bad
for you excuse me unless of course i
decided to withhold that information
tell everyone it was you who figured it
out why would you do that what do you
want oh
no way i actually had something else oh
no way
yeah
that's so nice
that's sweet
hello squad oh my god captain
good news
the vulture is out
and i'm back
[Applause]
where's gina uh she wanted to make a
proper entrance
[Laughter]
oh sweet
ah
ladies and gentlemen despite the fact
that this is
one of the lowest performing view count
consistent things we do on the channel i
have decided that i love this show so
much we are not doing anything else we
were only reacting to brooklyn
seven times a week seven times a week
and if anything big comes out sorry
sorry guys you gotta be well rested for
brooklyn
because we gotta shoot those first thing
every morning 6 a.m
yeah this is a really good show that was
sweet that was really sweet
and you know what i like genome i think
we like gina more than the average
person and yeah she's really really
really grown on me you us as a character
i remember those early episodes being
like i don't know man i don't know if
we'll be aboard the gina train now every
time she shows up i'm like let's go
yeah
let's let's go
here are 12 reasons why gina is the best
character
oh you're doing a superstar i would
never
he knows my name
it took a while
hey real rejects
yeah
yeah yeah yeah he knows my name i'm
craig's friend
oh that's my that's what john means in
in hebrew it's greg's friend greg's
friend
so yeah that was great
it was really good it was really
surprisingly heartwarming at the end i
didn't see that coming at all no
i thought it was just gonna like you
know something about sacrificing credit
oh what a bunch of [ __ ] i thought he
was gonna dunk on that guy who would
dunk on that
anus who would sacrifice credit it is
the most important thing in life why do
anything unless you can get recognized
yeah i can't relate to peralta
whatsoever
this is a bad real badly written
character
are you trying to come across like
you sacrifice credit
no
what's going on i don't know
i don't know what's happening
i'm just i'm just riffing
do i sacrifice credit i mean i don't uh
uh
go seeking
credit to be cred i don't go look at me
guys my contribution i don't i don't
actively do that
because i don't discredit it a lot
though john i i am given much credit uh
not not half of which maybe even
no leave it
enjoy it
here's your plate of credit
please sir i want some more
oh it's regretting please
more credit
i'm going to eat my
credit
credit
that's what i do when i go to the bank
that's what i do when i want recognition
works everywhere
anywhere there's credit to be had
best way to get credit is ask for it yep
every every short film i've ever worked
on don't wait for your work to wait for
your work to pay off to get credit
um no
although no that's a really sweet thing
especially when that was like his whole
childhood dream apparently did
i imagine if you want to be a detective
that is kind of a childhood dream is to
if your passion is becoming a detective
wanting to catch a killer yeah
yeah
be in the thick of it get into the real
danger and bring down a menace i hope
season six or something decides to go
all out with like
um like a like a hannibal lecter thing
yeah he has to work alongside his yeah
it worked as long as i keep visiting him
and asking her about like this becomes a
serialized television depraved character
played by will arnett or something like
that that would be so funny
i would love that i would absolutely
love that or maybe they should try to do
that like a funny
silence of the lambs i think
funny i think my best ideas are on this
show when we were talking about it
that's why brooklyn is the
best i forget everything i ever [ __ ]
but
yeah you got a record you could just go
back and watch all these reviews funny
silence of the layouts
that's that's the pitch right there yeah
like a comedic having to work with a
serial killer like a dark comedy yeah
you could
i think it's like simultaneously intense
yeah it's like still like yeah gritty
and
gory you know yeah we're really going to
ride the fine line here
really grim and gruesome real-life
depictions of death and dismemberment
but
with the humorous character-driven angle
every review is gonna be this show
doesn't know what tone it wants to be it
oscillates wildly between silly comedy
and depraved violence
who's the market
now
streaming yeah that was um
uh that was cool
yeah i really like grew to dislike the
vulture in this episode
like genuinely
before it was like i like to not like
you that was the feeling is
you're such an [ __ ] and i enjoy not
liking you
and this one was like i really don't
like you
here you're frustrated you're yeah
you're an annoying guy yeah as much as
it can be amusing the way you foil our
characters i would i would never want to
ever work for you
that would be the worst place to work
and this guy this actor constantly plays
like skeezy leeches
so i wonder if he's like at that at all
normally or not normally they find out
the actors like no it's just
what they're good at playing
is a humanitarian a philanthropist
he has no earthly possessions he's the
best man on earth like that straight
talking cocky [ __ ] like he's really
he's really good at playing that role
um
but i mean he even put him on like 30
rock he was like tina fey's boyfriend
for the longest time
he's like a more slackery version of
this character yeah the same thing
what's going on dummy yeah yeah or even
mayhem does all the mayhem commercials
it's the same thing it's the same
attitude yeah uh so i enjoy them but
yeah this episode was like oh thank god
they
pushed him out finally yeah excuse me
frustrating it was interesting also
seeing what
it really dawned on me of um
andre brauer this time too of how he was
like he's really doing like a
an arc this season like he's doing a
performance
like he
like a character of a guy who's slowly
losing his soul yeah to this work and
then you know it like that scene the
diner uh when he's yelling at jake
and i was like my dream was to run the
nine-nine that's never gonna happen give
this a major crime like that scene when
he just yelled at him whoa wow that's
that's been like he's
this is a real performer you know what i
mean like it's not just funny he's a
real performance around this time
absolutely it's always has i don't want
i want to clarify it always has been
it's just it really felt like they dived
into something much deeper with him over
the course of these last four episodes
yeah what struck me part way through
this one that even i mean even though it
does kind of reset and we get him back
by the end of this i was sitting there
going you know this could have felt this
having the vulture be in charge and
having him be over at pr like this could
have felt like okay when are we gonna
get past this and it started that i
didn't reach that idea in quite those
terms but i was sitting there going you
know i could continue watching this
doesn't feel as unnatural as you would
think because you know at the end of
season two it's the big sort of oh no
how will we continue and it's like
they've done a nice job of incorporating
that storyline in a way that doesn't
feel random or detached too much so like
yeah i think it's a big credit to his
performance and the writing of that
stuff that yeah makes it actually feel
like a natural part of the show and then
yeah i mean when he comes back here
it is very
rewarding
uh but at the same time they could have
easily kept that going and i wouldn't
have been upset about it however the way
they brought him back i thought was yeah
really really wonderful and it and it
honors that scene in the diner but takes
it to a slightly different place
also the show really shows you how
corrupt
the
full force fit is
true the yeah was just like yeah i'll
take the credit and reinstate his job if
you let me take the credit like
no i
might not be like you know it's really
honorable that you're willing to
sacrifice the credit
um
let me reinstate and we'll still get the
credit
what the [ __ ]
no no it's just that guy gets what he
wants i scratched him
you scratched my back
i mean that is funny too because i mean
as much as this show is about cops it is
you can say it has to take place from a
somewhat pro-police perspective it does
seem like most of the people around them
are not good people no no no and they're
they're the few who are good the b99
it was only a matter of time before we
finally got fat terry you know it was
inevitable the amount of things about
you know his ripped body and everything
you're bound for that inevitable sitcom
episode
when terry gets fat good fat makeup
he gained so much weight in the course
of a month in an afternoon he did like
super size me [ __ ] you know like he
gained so much weight
it's
it's no real way it was comedic i get it
what it was like you wouldn't gain that
much weight that fast from your diet how
much are you eating at home exactly
although if you're not working out
yeah that makes sense
if you are just eating and you know to
maintain the kind of physique that he
has he has to consume a lot of food so
if he's eating the same amount of food
probably more without exercise i could i
could see it because of that muscle
would actually convert into fat i've
changed my mind it's possible
good probably possible yeah it's good
this is a new segment is your favorite
comedy plot line plausible there is
something that is so
it's the cheapest gag
fat suit it's the cheapest gag
and it
tends to work on me for some reason
monica and friends
ryan reynolds at the beginning of just
friends
uh dwayne johnson and central
intelligence
terry here there's something about
fat
that's super it's funny because let's
see because you know you're not really
really fat
so this is automatically absurd buddy
it's so absurd
it's funnier to me when i get the
impression that these are people who
probably have to do a lot of intense
focus and maintenance to
ensure they can stay physically fit it's
really hard you know like i can gain
weight really easy
and then if i focus up for like two
weeks i can lose weight so it's really
my weight goes like up and down all the
time so uh that's my good kick out of it
because i struggle with struggling with
weight since i was like
two
so that's time to start
get on that morphia train boy
so yeah
anyway brooklyn nine-nine
thanks for being here people
this is such a fun show such a fun show
uh leave uh
something page for the day shout out
maria hammond maria
took me long enough
not usually a sweater guy
then lately i've been wearing sweaters
which is an odd time considering the way
the weather's been today
and then you gave us this sweater that i
opted to
call my own um
i've got one too a while ago and then i
was like i gotta wear it for brooklyn
nine-nine
and because you know
so i think that's apt
with die hard these days that we covered
i gotta say i'm pretty comfortable in
that maria thank you thank you it's
comfy
look at that
man no my sweater's ruined you smell so
good my sweater's been ruined by your
oils i have a nakatomi plaza one i'll
just give it to you as a tithe for this
indiscretion
the maria also has a lot of good words
in one sentence
i learned them all from maria
maria
thank you dear you are
just a
just a blast bee's knees and uh we have
a showdown match coming up i don't know
if you still follow that [ __ ]
but if you do
please
watch it and leave a comment
because
you are
an angel in our hearts
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
it's all part of the plan maria
fact fat fact
this is a fact
when they're saying that in batman
my genuine thoughts
real maria
my genuine thought was
i wish i saw a west side story so i knew
what he was referencing
[Laughter]
i thought it was a west side story right
it it is it is we're just gonna go
because i remember and analyzed that de
niro it's like maria so i was like
i think that's the same song yes
it's definitely
i want a re-imagined version of west
side story with all that sort of choral
music it wasn't until the coral church
time i watched it when i asked olivia
what does that mean and she told me and
i was like
yeah i thought that was west side story
this whole time
like it's just some random song he's
singing and the movie must have a deep
meaning
yep he made it up
[Music]